E aí
é a minha vó Lili ela é minha principal
referência de cozinha e eu lembro bem
que quando eu era criança lá em Salvador
quando eu não tava dentro da Maré
brincando eu tava correndo em volta da
série de minha avó eu ficava muito com
minha avó porque meus pais saíram para
trabalhar meus irmãozinhos para escola e
eu ficava em casa com minha avó e meu
avô meu avô é para rua e eu ficava lá
com ela e a gente estava sempre na
cozinha eu tava ali sempre conversando
com ela ou comendo o estudando
Assistindo TV mas eu lembro bem que
minha vó tava sempre cozinhando e eu
ficava ali assistindo aquilo o olho no
Xou da Xuxa e o olho espetáculos de
minha avó
Ah e eu não consegui entender como que
minha avó fazia aquela mágica de pegar
um peixe fresco e transformar numa
moqueca
o meu avô ele vinha da rua e ele trazia
peixe fresco ele trazer a corvina ele
trazia tainha ele trazer a peixe
vermelho e ela entregava aquele peixe a
minha avó e a minha voz sentava na tampa
de um tanque que tinha no pátio da casa
da gente aí ela abre as pernas e
colocava no meio das pernas uma bacia de
alumínio cheia de água com gelo e aí ela
pegava aquele peixe ali e ela limpava o
peixe todo ela disse que amava peixe
todo aí depois ela cortava as barbatanas
e a ponta do rabo do peixe depois ela
enfiava o dedo na goela do peixe e
puxava as partes de dentro dele aí ela
pegava a faca e abrir o peixe inteirinho
assim pelo lado limpava a parte de
dentro aí ela trocava o peixe de água
pegava uma banda de limão passava no
peixe todo Quando estivesse passando um
sabão para lavar o peixe e deixava esse
peixe
é uma outra bacia com água com gelo e
limão
e me conta uma das chaves lá ela
começava a segunda parte do espetáculo
dela ela pegava todos os temperos armava
em cima da pia pegava um pilão de
madeira colocar nos dentes de alho
colocava sal e aí ela mas será vi aquilo
até virar uma pasta aí ela pegava o
limão apertar vai tirar aquele suco bem
fresquinho envolvia tudo fazer um creme
aí pegava o peixe tirar o excesso de
água do peixe fazer um rasgo de cada
lado do peixe e pegava Esse creme e
massageava Cipreste todinho por dentro e
por fora aí colocava ali dentro da
geladeira
lá e pegava toda aquela que ele tempero
colorido toda aquela comida com aquela
cor linda da culinária da Bahia e ela
montava aquela panela Mística sabe cheia
de sabor cheia de camadas de cores cheia
de camada dos seres mais inebriantes que
eu já senti na minha vida ela pegava
esse peixe e deitava em cima dessa cama
e ligar para o fogo
E aí antes dela desligar essa panela ela
rezava essa comida toda com leite de
coco
Oi e aí ela ganhava essa comida também
com azeite de dendê que coloria e trazer
o aroma
E aí ela finalizada com outras gotas de
limão tampa a panela desligar o fogo e
ela servia a gente
bom e quando minha avó servir a gente
ela serviu alimento mais poderoso que eu
já conheci na minha vida porque naquele
prato que ela colocava ali só não
colocava só a comida deliciosa dela ela
tava contando toda a história da nossa
família
e isso é tão forte para mim que eu
lembro que com oito anos de idade eu já
tava anunciando para o mundo que eu
queria ter uma lanchonete porque eu
queria servir a comida preferida de todo
mundo que aparecesse na minha casa anos
depois de adulta em 2005 estudando
comunicação social em Salvador tava
doida para cair no mundo para conhecer a
vida e aí eu consegui uma oportunidade
de trabalho aqui em São Paulo e eu vim
para cá
Ah e quando eu chegar aqui de dentro da
cozinheira de dentro da comunicadora
saiu uma cozinheira só é uma cozinheira
apaixonada acusei ela mais faminta mas
isso meada para aprender cada vez mais
uma pessoa que tava vendo que ali tava
encontrando um fio para o vazio que não
sabia nem de onde vinha
o e naquele momento ali eu não tinha
sonhos eu não tinha expectativas mas eu
me apaixonei pela possibilidade de das
minhas mãos eu tirar o que para mim ela
todo meu sustento eu achava incrível a
ideia das minhas mãos saírem a minha
comida e o meu dinheiro mal sabia eu que
eu tava iniciando ali na verdade uma
caminhada de encontro a mim mesmo a
minha história e aos meus sonhos eu
passei vários anos cozinhando em São
Paulo e um tempo depois eu voltei para
Bahia e quando eu voltei para Bahia eu
voltei com a mente super em quieta cheia
de questões sem saber para onde ir e no
meio daquela loucura toda eu conheci o
Museu da Gastronomia baiana quer uma
super escola de culinária que fica no
centro histórico de Salvador no lugar
onde as pessoas conhecem como Pelourinho
o que que foi o lugar que além de me
trazer e instrumentação para desenvolver
as minhas habilidades práticas e
técnicas de cozinha eu ganhei de
presente uma biblioteca uma biblioteca
recheada de palavras que eu chamo de
informações de libertação porque a mim
essas informações tão libertando até
hoje
de dentro daquela escola ali eu comecei
a conhecer um pouco da história da minha
família comecei a entender um pouco
sobre a magia da minha avó
e foi ali também que eu percebi que das
minhas mãos saíram bolas de fogo foi ali
que eu percebi que eu poderia produzir
um alimento foi a primeira vez na minha
vida que eu me enxerguei como uma pessoa
foi quando percebi que eu tinha uma
história para contar e foi ali que eu
decidi que eu ia mudar minha vida
a e foi ali que eu percebi que eu tinha
uma história para contar que eu pude
respirar outras pessoas eu me conectei
tanto que eu recebi meus sonhos de volta
e para além de receber meus sonhos de
volta eu percebi que eu tinha toda a
capacidade de realizar esses sonhos
e me conectei com a minha intuição de
irmãos a ela e continue caminhando
Porque na minha cabeça eu tinha que me
preparar porque quando o meu sonho
passasse na minha frente eu tinha que
estar pronta para abraçar ele não deixar
ele fugir de mim e aí em 2017 eu fui
para uma palestra da Jamila Ribeiro lá
em Salvador e muito nervosa no fim da
palestra eu convidei ela para ela comer
na minha casa a moqueca que eu tinha
aprendido a fazer com minha avó olhando
minha vó fazer na infância e ela olhou
dentro do meu olho falou eu vou eu vou
almoçar na sua casa e ela foi e nesse
dia eu convidei outras mulheres negras e
a gente se reuniu mais uma vez um grupo
de mulheres negras atravessando o meu
caminho e marcando a minha vida em volta
da mesa em volta do alimento que eu
aprendi a fazer com a minha vó Lili
e nós estávamos ali trocando e
celebrando a nossa existência através do
alimento o alimento que me trouxe até
aqui e o alimento que me trouxe de volta
a minha humanidade e depois essa moqueca
desse almoço que eu fiz meu telefone não
parou mais de tocar procurando por
reserva naquele momento ali brotava da
terra a semente do meu sonho de ter uma
lanchonete quando eu era criança
tá bom Eu não abri a minha lanchonete
mas não entre outros negócios Hoje eu
tenho um restaurante que se chama casa
da dona Lili em homenagem a minha avó
que a minha inspiração e é o começo
dessa linha incrível invisível que me
traz hoje até aqui eu Saúdo a minha avó
e a todas as minhas astrais porque saber
da existência delas hoje é o meu grande
poder
o Acará significa bola de fogo G
significa comer em orubá acarajé
significa comer bola de fogo eu agradeço
a culinária afro-brasileira por todo
discernimento e entendimento que ela tem
me trazido hoje quando eu coloco uma
karajeh para fritar dentro de um tacho
cheio de dendê fervendo eu tenho plena
certeza eu sei que cada bola daquela
lista fritando somos nós nós as mulheres
negras em prontidão somos as bolas de
fogo que acendem e realizam a revolução
Muito obrigado
e o
[Aplausos]
E aí